Winteroffensive Frühjahrsoffensive seit
Wochen wird mit diesem Begriffen über
eine mögliche Wende im Krieg gegen die
Ukraine gesprochen die Kämpfe im Osten
des Landes gehen weiter der Westen hat
Raketenabwehrsysteme geliefert polen
will Kampfjets schicken kann die Ukraine
die russischen Truppen zurückdrängen
Zweifel daran wurden durch
veröffentlichte amerikanische
Geheimdienst Dokumente genährt der
Konflikt mitten in Europa hat längst
eine globale Dimension in dem vor allem
die USA und China ihren Machtkampf
Proben ein verhandlungsfrieden ist nicht
in sich so auch Annalena bärburg die
bundesaußenministerin heute im Bundestag
Putin gegen die Ukraine droht ein
langjähriger Krieg unser Thema heute in
der phönix-runde
als ich das letzte Mal hier bei der
regierungsbefragung war war das kurz
nach dem brutalen russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine und
niemand wusste damals wie lange dieser
Krieg andauern würde wir alle haben
gehofft dass er schnell wieder zufrieden
kommt leider war das anders trotz der
intensiven Friedensbemühungen von
unserer Seite von Seite unserer
europäischen Freunde von eigentlich so
gut wie der ganzen Welt die
bundesaußenministerin heute Mittag bei
der Befragung der Bundesregierung ganz
herzlich willkommen zur Phönix Runde aus
Berlin ja reden wir wieder einmal über
diesen Krieg aus verschiedenen
Perspektiven mit diesen Gästen ich
begrüße Rüdiger von Fritsch er ist
ehemaliger Diplomat er war von 2014 bis
2019 Botschafter in Moskau ist jetzt
Partner des Beratungsunternehmens global
advisors und er ist Autor sein neues
Buch über die Welt im Umbruch erscheint
im Mai ich begrüße ganz herzlich
Professor Gerhard er unterrichtet
Politikwissenschaften mit dem
Schwerpunkt internationale Beziehungen
und Sicherheit im Post sowjetischen Raum
an der Universität Innsbruck herzlich
willkommen ihnen und herzlich willkommen
Marina komm herzlich willkommen Marina
combaki sie ist Redakteurin im
hauptstadtbüro des Spiegel mit dem
Schwerpunkt grüne und Außenpolitik und
hat die Außenministerin gerade nach
Japan und China begleitet Erik
Kirschbaum ist bei uns US-amerikanischer
Journalist er hat und oder erarbeitet
unter anderem für die Los Angeles Times
Annalena baerbock hat es gesagt wir
haben gehofft vor einem Jahr das ist
irgendwie schnell zu Ende ging das
scheint jetzt nicht mehr so Herr Fritsch
wie wahrscheinlich ist ein langjähriger
Krieg
wie lange dieser Krieg dauert und wie er
ausgeht hängt im wesentlichen davon ab
wie die Wette auf die Zeit die Wladimir
Putin eingegangen ist ausgeht denn er
geht eine doppelte Wette ein er setzt
darauf dass wir nachlassen in unserer
Bereitschaft die Ukraine entschlossen zu
unterstützen dass es ihm gelingt uns zu
zerlegen auseinander zu nehmen und die
andere Wetter auf die Zeit die
eingegangen ist bei sich zu Hause wird
es ihm gelingen dauerhaft ein Krieg der
schlecht für ihn verläuft der zu einem
Debakel für ihn geworden ist dennoch zu
Hause durchzusetzen wird es ihm gelingen
seine Diktatur aufrecht zu halten mit
den klassischen Mitteln der russischen
Diktatur nämlich Repression umfassend
mit der großen Lüge der Propaganda und
drittens seiner Möglichkeit sich ständig
Zustimmung zu erkaufen und das ist eine
Achillesferse deswegen sind unsere
Sanktionen richtig wo sie ansetzen und
wir sehen dass seine Möglichkeiten dort
erheblich inzwischen eingeschränkt sind
und beschädigt
ich habe gesagt sie kommen gerade aus
Japan und China waren mit der
Außenministerin auch zum G7 treffen wie
sehr wenn man sich da umhört geht man
davon aus dass dieser Krieg noch lange
dauert der Krieg dauert ja bereits schon
eine ganze Weile er hat ja nicht erste
vergangenen Jahr begonnen er hat 2014
mit der Annexion der Krim begonnen mit
den dann folgenden vermeintlichen
separatistischen Bewegungen im Don Bass
und mein Eindruck aus dem g7-gipfel in
Japan ist das
niemand sich darauf einstellt dass
dieser Krieg sehr bald enden wird es
gibt die Hoffnung dass aus diesem Krieg
ein sowas wie ein eingefrorener Konflikt
wird aber wie das hängt von der
erwarteten gegen Offensive der Ukraine
habe er mein Gott das ist ja auch die
also so ein Stichwort wie Frau kommt
Baki gerade ein eingefrorener Konflikt
oder eben ein langjähriger Krieg was
worauf würden sie setzen
ich denke es wird noch ein langer Krieg
werden ein eingefrorener Konflikt würde
jetzt Russland beurteilen und diejenigen
die fordern dass jetzt verhandelt werden
soll die meinen eben auch das Russland
die Gebiete die es jetzt besetzt hält
zumindest eine Zeit lang behalten soll
und diejenigen die sagen die Ukraine
soll nicht mit Waffen beliefert werden
oder nicht mehr mit Waffen geliefert
werden die müssen sagen dass sie
billigen den kaufen nehmen dass die
Ukraine diese kriegt dann verlieren wird
ich rechne also noch mit einem längeren
Krieg und kann nur bestätigen was der
Botschafter gesagt hat nämlich dass man
in Moskau jetzt in diesem Jahr mit
dieser Frühjahrsoffensive der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte denn
Höhepunkte westlichen Unterstützung für
die Ukraine gegeben sieht und man
erwartet dass sollte vor allem diese
Offensive nicht verfolgreich sein gegen
Jahresende die Kriegsmüdigkeit im Westen
durchschlägt und Druck entsteht auf die
Ukraine sich doch an einen
verhandlungsstisch zu setzen aber
derzeit ist für eine Verhandlungslösung
nicht mal was Verhandlungen über eine
Waffenruhe betrifft überhaupt kein
Spielraum gegeben beide Seiten sagen
zwar sie sein bereit zu verhandeln sie
stellen nur jeweils Bedingungen an die
andere Seite die für die jeweils andere
Seite nicht akzeptabel sind Herr Kirsch
ja dann ganz stark davon ab wie stark
die Unterstützung für die Ukraine
weitergeht jetzt ein Stichwort wie
Kriegsmüdigkeit haben Sie den Eindruck
dass die USA auf jeden Fall so lange wie
es dauert an der Seite der Ukraine
stehen werden ja das ist die Position
der beiden Regierung ich kann nur sagen
ich glaube für die Amerikaner ist
Freiheit viel wichtiger Frieden und ich
glaube für die Ukrainer ist Freiheit
auch viel wichtiger als Ukraine Frieden
und deswegen glaube ich dass die
Amerikaner eine Zeit lang so lange diese
Präsident im Amt ist ohne unerschöpft
weitere Ukraine und die Freiheit Ukraine
einsetzt das ist wirklich die Priorität
der Amerikaner ist Freiheit nicht
unbedingt Frieden und Flüge keine auch
egal bin Ukraine redet keine von von
Frieden es wichtiger aus Freiheit oder
wir sind bedeuten wahrscheinlich keine
Freiheit mehr aber sie haben die
Einschränkung gemacht das ist hängt an
dem jetzigen Präsidenten genau wer weiß
was in zwei Jahren passieren könnte die
Republikaner haben andere Töne zwischen
Töne aber die Republikaner waren
eigentlich immer eine Partei die sehr
stark gegenüber die Sowjetunion standen
und deswegen weiß ich nicht was
passieren kann aber ich glaube
Republikaner auch die der Kurs von
beiden unterstützen im Senat z.B wir
sehen die republikanische Senat ist auch
sehr
fest im Sattel mit der Kurs von den
beiden Regierung deswegen mein Sohn noch
nicht so vieles malen das ist anders
werden könnte schauen wir zuerst auf
Russland von Botschafter dort in Moskau
und in der letzte Woche hat er einen
Blog für Aufsehen gesorgt nämlich der
das sollte eine Chef sehr sehr seltener
Gruppe Wagner hat geschrieben für die
Staatsmacht und für die Gesellschaft ist
es heute notwendig irgendeinen dicken
Punkt hinter die militärische
spezialoperation
zu setzen wie muss man denn das
verstehen
man sieht da die politische
Unzulänglichkeit dieses stumpfen
Söldener Führers denn er hat
gleichzeitig nachgeschoben das ist dafür
natürlich keine Verhandlung geben wird
das heißt seine Idee ist die eines
diktatfriedens der stellt sich vor die
Ukraine geben auf und überlassen ihre
Landsleute in den von Russland eroberten
annektiert und besetzten Gebieten im
schrecklichen Schicksal dass sie jetzt
bereits erleben das ist keine Position
die in irgendeiner Form auf ein
Kriegsende Zielen würde dass im
Interesse der Ukraine wäre in unserem
Interesse aber auch nicht im Interesse
weil er mehr Brötchens denn er hat das
ist dürfen wir nicht vergessen ja sehr
viele weiterreichende Ziele verkündet
als er diesen Krieg begonnen hat erzählt
ja nicht nur auf die Ukraine der hat ja
DCD von uns verlangt dass wir uns selber
Schwächen weil er selber als Land
schwach ist hofft er dadurch dass er uns
schwächt sich selber Stärken zu können
dass die große Rechnung das Ziel
verfolgt der weiter und das ist der
größere Hintergrund auch zu diesem Krieg
den Blick behalten müssen aber wie muss
man diesen das verstehen welche Rolle
spielt ich trink auch schon gleich
können Sie dazu noch mal was sagen
ist ein Instrument der russischen
Politik und er ist bislang auch abhängig
von Wladimir Putin das ist ja nicht der
erste Krieg den er für Vladimir Putin
führt er hat ja bereits in Syrien in
Zentralafrika in Libyen Krieg für
Russland geführt ein ganz billiges
Instrument der Kriegsführung
ursprünglich hatte man sich auch immer
von ihm distanziert aber er hat klare
Ziele im Interesse der russischen
Militärführung verfolgt und sich vor Ort
immer finanzieren können das waren sehr
billiges Mittel der Kriegsführung jetzt
ist offensichtlich dass er ganz klar ein
Teil der russischen Militärmaschine ist
deren brutalster aber er ist kein
eigenständiger Faktor auch er muss davon
ausgehen dass Putin gegen ihn ein
Dossier in der Schublade hat er wäre
insofern auch von seiner eigenen
Kapazität ja gar nicht geeignet einen
erfolgreicher Präsident Russland zu sein
gleichwohl wäre er jemand der bereit
wäre sich auf die Seite denkbarer
Putschisten umschlagen sollte es denn zu
versuchen eines Umsturzes in Russland
kommen was ja nicht völlig
auszuschließen ist er hat ja auch selber
politische Ambitionen begründet ja in St
Petersburg er hat in den vergangenen
Monaten wiederholt die russische Armee
kritisiert dafür dass seine Truppen
angeblich
nicht ausreichend Munition bekleben
nicht ausreichend Ausrüstung Rückhalt
begeben begeben von den russischen
Streitkräften da zeigt sich der zeigt
sich eine Reibung da zeigt sich ein Riss
der möglicherweise auf ja Rivalitäten
innerhalb der russischen Polit Elite
deuten könnte aber das ist jetzt nichts
worauf der Westen hoffen sollte weil die
bessere Alternative ist er ganz gewesen
ja
Professor Chef so etwas schreibt was
sagt das über die ja auch grundsätzlich
über die Stärke der russischen
Streitkräfte aus
ich denke man muss diese Äußerung von
libosin wie folgt interpretieren es gibt
in der russischen Führung in der zivilen
wie in der militärischen russischen
Führung eine Debatte darüber was
eigentlich die russischen Kriegsziele
zumindest die kurzfristigen russischen
Kriegsziele sein sollen da gibt es ein
Lager das sagt wir müssen weiter
versuchen zusätzliches Territorium zu
erobern zumindest alle Gebiete zu die
die zu diesen vier ukrainischen Regionen
gehören die Russland als Teil seines
eigenen Staatsgebietes betrachtet und es
gibt ein anderes Lager das sagt nein wir
sollten uns defensiv aufstellen und das
was wir bis jetzt der Robert haben
halten auch gegen einen ukrainische
früher Offensive und diese Äußerung von
trikotin mit diesem Blog Eintrag zeigt
dass er in dem Lage ist das eher
defensiv denkt dass er in dem Lage ist
das früheren Oberkommandierenden der
russischen Truppen in der Ukraine
general zu Kind und sich gegen general
grassimo stellt den generalstoff-
Auftrag Putins mit dem mit den
Forderungen Putins auf eine weitere
Ausdehnung der besetzten Gebiete setzt
also das ist aber die Frage ja wenn man
das schaut wie wie kompliziert es dann
auch innerhalb der russischen Führung
ist kann man daraus irgendeine Hoffnung
nehmen also ich sehe das nicht als eine
wirkliche
Rivalität sondern er bedient auch die
sentimente eines Teils der
Öffentlichkeit es gibt in Russland
Rechte Nationalisten sozusagen jenseits
von Putin die im Moment noch eine
gewisse Rolle spielen dazu gehören viele
militärblogger und andere mehr und er
hat ein Stück weit das Recht diese Rolle
einzunehmen deren Interessen zu bedienen
für die Lautstärke zu sein damit auch
die zufriedene stellt sind und der
versucht in der jetzt unternommen hat
selbst politisch aktiv zu werden zeigt
wie stark er sich im Machtgefüge bewegt
er ist dabei eine der Blockparteien
diesen Russland ja unverändert gibt mehr
oder weniger zu übernehmen das heißt man
würde ihm erlauben dort eine Rolle zu
spielen aber alles wie gesagt
unter der Kontrolle des Präsidenten die
komplizierter geworden ist
hat tatsächlich große politischen
Ambitionen aber er hat im Geheimdienst
in Russland vor allem im
Inlandsgeheimdienst den FSB so viele
Feinde dass ich es nicht für möglich
halte dass er in eine Führungsspitze in
eine Führungsposition gelang geschweige
denn in die Position des Präsidenten ich
habe zu Beginn schon gesagt dieser
dieser Konflikt dieser Kriegs mehr und
mehr natürlich als ein Konflikt dieser
dieser Krieg hat eben diese globale
Dimension gerade auch durch diese
Rivalität zwischen den USA und China
Frau kompakte sie waren gerade in China
welche Rolle spielt dieser Krieg in
China und wie will man sozusagen damit
seine Machtposition verstärkt ja es war
die große Frage mit der auch die
Außenministerin dahin gereist ist wie
positioniert sich China in diesem
Konflikte in diesem Krieg es gab ja die
Hoffnung dass China sein Einfluss
gegenüber Moskau geltend machen würde
und ähm die Eindrücke mit denen wir der
aus Peking abgereist sind haben diese
Hoffnung keineswegs genährt also China
profitiert von diesem Krieg es
profitiert davon dass der Westen sehr
stark davon absorbiert ist dass der
Westen sehr viel investiert sehr viel
gibt zur Verteidigung der Ukraine es
profitiert auch von einem wie sie den
anscheinend hat zunehmend geschwächten
Russland davon das Russland sich in
tiefer in die Abhängigkeit Chinas begibt
und
offenbar hat die chinesische Führung
bislang jedenfalls keinerlei Ambitionen
auf Moskau einzuwirken den seine Truppen
abzuziehen ja es gibt zwar diese
wagenbekundungen dass man dass man dass
man für für Frieden eintreten wolle aber
diese vermeintliche Friedensplan von dem
Zeitlang die Rede gewesen ist in dem
taucht das Wort krieg ja keineswegs
vorher also die Chinesen verweigern sich
ein Stück weit veröffentlich zumindest
auch der Anerkennung der Tatsache mit
dem Blick in die USA wie sehr welche
Rolle spielt der Ukraine Krieg in dieser
Auseinandersetzung zwischen USA
ja ich meine es ist nicht hilfreich wenn
der französische Präsident in Frankreich
ist und dann solche Äußerungen mag dann
am gleichen republikanische
Senatoren wie Rubio gesagt ja dann kann
die Europäer Ukraine alleine verteidigen
das ist nicht so hilfreich aber es ist
spielt keine große Rolle eigentlich aber
ja
okay aber man merkt schon wenn macron
sagt mir wir müssen nicht nur wir müssen
überlegen an welcher Seite wir da stehen
müssen nicht unbedingt an der Seite der
USA stehen dass das Verstimmungen führt
natürlich ist unsere Schock und die
Amerikaner erwarten dass die Europäer
immer mehr Führung in der Ukraine
übernehmen und eine große Rolle spielen
und ähm Deutschland schritt für schritt
langsam aber sicher macht mehr aber man
hört das immer wieder eine Marke
Deutschland könnte und sollte mehr
machen genau aber solche Äußerungen in
China das war ein Schock für mich und
viele Amerikaner dass man sowas sagt zum
Glück hat von der von der Lion
gleichzeitig durch entschieden hat was
anderes gesagt aber der
sPD-Fraktionsvorsitzender hat auch
gesagt wir müssen nicht unbedingt nur
die wahr sein Amerika sein
das hat heute die amerikanische
Botschafterin was Gutes gesagt sie hat
gesagt abgesehen von dem Begriff ist das
im Kern natürlich richtig weil die
Europäer alliierte sind und auch
unabhängig das ist ja schon wahr und
wenn man aber davon absieht dass
macron sehr weitgehende Äußerung
getätigt hat so hat er natürlich einen
richtigen Kern berührt nämlich die
Tatsache dass wir Europäer künftig in
der Lage sein müssen Außen- und
sicherheitspolitisch selbstständig
handlungsfähig zu sein mit Blick auf ein
denkbarer Entwicklung in den USA Ron the
Sandes gefragt was die wichtigsten aus
dem politischen Prioritäten sind hat der
vier aufgelistet der Ukraine kriegt kam
nicht vor er hat ein Regionalkonflikt
genannt von dem die USA sich Fragen
sollten ob sie da weiter engagiert
werden sollen das heißt die Europäer und
da hat man einen richtigen Kern sollten
sich auf gar keinen Fall von den USA
distanzieren oder lösen aber vorbereitet
sein auf eine Situation wo die
Amerikaner sich von uns lösen und da ist
Nachholbedarf in der europäischen
Debatte da fehlt auch bei uns der
strategische Diskurs in Deutschland muss
ich sagen der auf Vorschläge von macron
die manchmal sehr französisch sind
eingeht das Wesentliche aufgreift und
darüber nachdenkt wie kann Europa als
eigenständige Akteur in Zukunft dann tun
können die falsche Zeit und der falschen
Ort an diese Bekundungen
zu der Frage welches Interesse
eigentlich der Konflikt der der Krieg in
der Ukraine zurzeit einnimmt ich fand
das doch bemerkenswert auf dem G7
Außenminister treffen jetzt in Japan das
doch sehr deutlich vernehmbar war ein
eine Fokus Verlagerung eine
Fokusverschiebung ja die Ukraine der
Krieg in der Ukraine die Unterstützung
der Ukraine hat einen gewichtigen Teil
eingenommen und doch war
unverkennbar dass China und der Konflikt
mit China die aufziehende Konfrontation
zwischen den USA und China dass das
eigentlich dominante Thema gewesen ist
das sollte die Außenministerin heute
auch gesprochen im bei der Befragen der
Bundesregierung hat es gibt ja immer
dieses die Frage Rivale Wettbewerber
oder Partner systemrivale und sie sagte
noch mal das ist jetzt doch deutlich
mehr Rivale das so sieht sie ist Herr
mein Gott was ist die die richtige
Haltung dazu und wie sehr
kann Europa auch in diesem Verhältnis zu
China auch eben noch mal Einfluss nehmen
auf den Krieg in der Ukraine
ich glaube dass Europa da ich nicht
einiges wie man mit China umgehen sollen
da gibt es osteuropäischen Staaten aber
natürlich auch die Briten die der
Ansicht sind europa muss ich an die
Seite der Vereinigten Staaten Stellen
mit den Vereinigten Staaten einen Blog
bilden um gegen China den eigentlichen
Gegner des 21 jahrhunderts sich
aufzustellen und dann gibt es andere
Staaten macron hat sich besonders in
diese Richtung geäußert die sagen es ist
eben nicht so dass Europa sich
zwangsläufig auf die Seite der USA in
diesem Konflikt stellen muss Europa soll
seine eigene Agenda haben es hat doch
eigene Interessen in China und gegenüber
China also die Einigkeit besteht hier
nicht was ich ergänzen möchte zu den
Vorteilen diese so kleine Krieges für
China und was damit zusammenhängt ist
das natürlich stimmt das China
geopolitische profitiert US Ressourcen
sind an Europa gebunden weil es sich
nicht selber verteidigen kann Russland
wird strukturell abhängig aber es gibt
auch einen Nachteil du USA haben den
Druck monatlich verstärkt auf
europäische Staaten sich in Konflikt mit
China an die Seite der USA zu stellen
das wollen sie als Gegenleistung für die
Weiterführung des der Funktion des
sicherheitsgaranten für Europa und es
könnte für China tatsächlich dieser
druckdosa dann negativ ausfallen dass
wenn man von Frankreich absieht und
vielleicht von einiger von einigen
weniger wichtigen Ländern der Druck doch
so stark ist dass die Europäische Union
sich auf die us-linie festlegen lässt
und sich klar die Seite der USA stellt
vielleicht noch mal ein Wort sondern
Interessenlage Chinas das ist eine
doppelte china hat auch in diesem
Konflikt zwei Dinge ganz fest im Blick
erstens China und zweitens den großen
aufsteigenden Konflikt mit den USA und
wenn wir auf die Interessenlage Chinas
blicken so ist dieser Krieg auch zum
Nachteil China ist weil der Aufstieg
China ist natürlich davon abhängt das
ist seine Handels macht weltweit
entfalten kann und was hat Vladimir
Putin getan er hat auf wichtigen Ländern
auf den Märkten wichtiger Länder für
Rezession Inflation gesorgt für
nachlassende konsumentennachfrage und er
hat eine der wichtigsten Handelsrouten
Chinas nämlich jene durch Russland
hindurch zertreten und zerstört und er
hat die Chinesen immer schreckliches
Dilemma gebracht weil sie diesen Krieg
nicht beenden können Sie wissen nicht
wie weil sie nicht wollen können dass
ein anderer autoritärer Staat der
tendenziell an ihrer Seite steht
dramatisch geschwächt wird und weil sie
auf der anderen Seite dass das Wladimir
Putin verfolgt auch nicht beliebig
zulassen können sie haben ja Russland
sehr deutlich gewarnt vor dem Einsatz
von Nuklearwaffen und andere mehr das
heißt für jeder ist auch dieser Krieg
ein Dilemma und ich bin überzeugt werde
mir Brötchen mitbringen nicht sehr genau
gesagt haben was er hat er auch die
Chinesen überrascht haben und sie mit
einer Situation konfrontiert die auch
sich jeder schwierig ist weil sie
einerseits geopolitische Ambitionen
verfolgen aber andererseits eben ihre
Wirtschaftsinteressen das hängt zusammen
die Wirtschaftsinteressen sind gestört
die Außenministerin trifft ja immer
relativ deutlich geworden anders auch
als der Bundeskanzler etwas mehr
fort hat auch über China gesagt ich muss
sagen dass ich mich frage ich sehe das
wieso die chinesische Positionierung
bislang nicht die Aufforderung an den
Adresse Russland behindert den Krieg zu
stoppen das war auf dieser gemeinsame
Pressekonferenz ist das ein gutes eine
gute Art Einfluss zu nehmen zu sagen
also China auch viel stärker zu
kritisieren wie wird das in den USA
ich weiß nicht aber es klingt nicht klug
ich glaube sie ist gleich abgewiesen
worden und nach Hause geschickt wurden
von China oder ich habe das nicht so
eins
das Interesse bekundet selbst
vorbeizukommen der chinesische
Außenminister hat sich eben nicht
abschrecken lassen von diesen harten
Tönen von diesem Klartext sondern hat
gesagt dass er sehr gerne im Mai je nach
Berlin käme zur Vorbereitung der im Juni
stattfinden in Deutschland chinesischen
regierungskonsultation und das muss ich
sagen fand ich schon beachtlich also da
geht man hin fehlt eine andere Tonalität
als die die Deutschland bislang
gegenüber China an den Tag gelegt hat
und verbrennt damit niemanden offenbar
offenbar könnte ich Chinesen damit
umgehen so scheint ist wichtig ist dabei
immer ein es ist man geht ein schmalen
gerade dabei weil wir einerseits eine
Werte geleitete Politik natürlich
verfolgen müssen aber auf der anderen
Seite auch mit Realitäten umgehen und
ich denke es ist richtig andere im
unmittelbaren Gespräch und notfalls auch
öffentlich daran zu erinnern dass Prinz
Hähnchen verletzt werden die wir
gemeinsam vereinbart haben deswegen zum
Beispiel war es sehr gut dass die
Außenministerin in China gesagt hat die
Menschenrechte die hier verletzt werden
sind auch von China selber garantiert
worden mit der Unterzeichnung der
menschenrechtskater der Vereinten Nation
china hat vor wenigen Jahren ein Zusatz
in seine Verfassung aufgenommen dass die
Menschenrechte und Minderheitenrechte zu
respektieren sind und daran darf man
appellieren dass dann auch nicht
schulmeisterlich weil China an seine
eigenen Grundsätze appellierte erinnert
wird auf einer anderen Punkt kommen der
uns in den letzten Tagen letzten Wochen
beschäftigt hat das sind die die leaks
der die Pentagon liegt der
us-geheim-dokumente Kirschbaum die Frage
wie wird er im Moment drüber gesprochen
in Amerika darin war ja auch zu lesen
dass sie stärker der Ukraine nicht ganz
so groß wie vielleicht vorher gedacht
also was welchen Einfluss könnte das
haben auf den ja auf jeden Fall das war
ein Überraschung für viele wie wie
schwach die ukrainische Position ist wie
schnell das so keine ganz andere Grenze
geht und vielleicht kann das den ein
oder anderen Kutteln das auch in
Deutschland in Europa dass man mehr tun
musste bevor das zu spät ist ja das war
eine Überraschung das war ein League und
vor allem was mich überrascht ist wie
viel wie viele Leute Zugang zu diese
geheimen das sind tausende von Leuten
das waren 21-Jährige
Soldat in massachusett ja genau und ja
und vor allem ist es natürlich ein ein
peinlicher Leck die Amerikaner sind
wieder erwischt worden wie die andere
Präsident ausspionieren und so das
sollte nicht mehr passieren aber es ist
passiert halt ähm ja es ist groß sehr
peinlich das ist so passiert weil das
gab's ja auch schon vorher also das wer
hat da die Macht sozusagen oder warum
wurde dem nicht vorgebeugt dass sowas
nicht passieren kann
viele Leute die viel brüchtern und die
ähm genau das weiß ich auch nicht aber
ich bin gespannt in aber ist wirklich
vielleicht gut am Ende dass wir alle
bisschen wach geworden sind Ukraine hat
vielleicht nicht mehr viel Zeit und und
wenn diese Krieg ähm weiter so geht wir
können vielleicht deine böse
Überraschung und verlieren und dann gibt
es keine Freiheit nur Ukraine und dann
sind wir alle ein bisschen Russland
gefährliche Politik Professor mein Gott
wie würden sie das Bewerten also diese
leaks haben die irgendein Einfluss auf
den Verlauf des Krieges
und die letzten Informationen die hier
preisgegeben wurden sind Informationen
von Anfang März das heißt die Ukraine
hatte in der Zwischenzeit die
Möglichkeit und wird noch die nächsten
Wochen nutzen um die anlageoffensive zu
überdenken Sie zu verändern sie
umzubauen also insofern glaube ich nicht
dass so unangenehm diese leaks für den
ukrainische Seite auch sind und
eigentlich rechtfertigt dass die Ukraine
immer gezögert hat die USA tatsächlich
voll in ihre Kriegspläne
einzubauen dass die Ukraine ihre lernt
rauszieht ihre Konsequenzen daraus zieht
und dass das keine kriegsenscheidende
Wirkung hat auf die Frühjahrsoffensive
der das Landes das erwarte ich mir nicht
und könnte es tatsächlich dazu führen
Frau kommt dass man dass man noch sagt
ja wir müssen dann doch die eine noch
stärker unterstützen und dass man dann
wirklich auch diese Frühjahrsoffensive
jetzt sieht das bemerkenswert ist ja
dass die zentralen Aussagen dieser liegt
nämlich dass die Ukraine einen Eklat
hatten Munitionsmangel hat das ist ja
nicht neu das ist auch schon sehr sehr
lange es gibt die Bemühungen den zu
beheben aber offenbar und gewiss noch in
unzureichender Weise
hinzu kommt dass die Ukraine im
vergangenen Kriegs ja viele ihre
erfahrensten Soldaten verloren hat auch
das ist ein ist ein Manko das das ein
Riesenproblem darstellt für die
Offensive es fehlt es fehlt an
flugabwehrsystemen Sie haben es eigens
erwähnt aus Deutschland sind jetzt in
den vergangenen Tagen das patriot-system
das ihres Tee das hocheffiziente ihres
t-system eingetroffen
das ist nicht nichts aber ob es
tatsächlich reicht um bedeutende
Geländegewinne mit dieser Gegend
Offensive zu erzielen Parenthese was
genau bedeutet eigentlich bedeuten die
Geländegewinne also von welchem von
welchen also was sind eigentlich die die
Ziele die die Ukraine verfolgt das das
ist noch offen
was denken
ich wollte Dir nur sagen der Westen
formulierte immer dass man Ukrain
unterstützt es lange sie takes solange
es eben notwendig ist das Problem ist
nur dass ich glaube im Westen gibt es
keine Einigkeit darüber was dieses ist
was dieses it tatsächlich ist wozu
möchte man die Ukraine militärisch
befähigen was sind die Ziele die man für
die Ukraine in der Ukraine in diesem
Krieg gegen Russland unterstützen soll
das ist eine Debatte die hinter den
Kulissen schon geführt wird da gibt es
Staaten die diese maximalistische Logik
verfolgen die die Regierung hier
verständlicherweise vertreten nämlich
zurückerobern aller Gebiete die zwei
Seiten 2014 verloren wurden da gibt's
aber auch andere Regierungen die sagen
könnten wir uns nicht wegen des
eskalationsrisikos einer solchen
maximalistischen Strategie mit weniger
zufrieden geht zum Beispiel mit der
Rückführung der russischen Truppen meine
Frontlinie vom 23 Februar also es wäre
auf der westlichen Seite wirklich offen
zu diskutieren was dieses it was dieses
ist was soll erreicht werden und was
will man der Ukraine ermöglichen und
wozu sie befähigen oder Freiheit gibt
man der Ukraine selber zu entscheiden
Punkt im Professor Mangold hier macht
und wir sind wieder an dem Punkt unser
mangelnden strategiefähigkeit wir sind
nicht Kriegspartei wir haben keine
Kriegsziele aber wir sollten
Vorstellungen davon haben wie kann eine
Wirklichkeit jenseits eines Krieges auch
aussehen und dazu bedarf es eines
miteinander wir müssen uns
zusammensetzen und über diese wie
Professor Mangold richtig geschildert
hat Teil sehr divergierenden
Vorstellungen unseren Ländern wo wollen
wir die ganze Situation hinführen im
Ergebnis die natürlich die die
wesentlichen Akteure im Westen also die
Regierung unserer Staaten sich
zusammensetzt und darüber belegen und
damit auch eine Vorstellung davon
entwickeln wie könnte eine
Friedenslösung aussehen denn die kann
man sich ja heute bereits vorstellen man
kann ja Ideen dazu entwickeln wie könnte
eine Friedenslösung Aussehen erstens wir
müssen entschlossen der Ukraine zur
Seite stehen und sie in in der Lage
bringen auf Augenhöhe nach eigenen
Vorstellungen ihre nationale
Souveränität zu bewahren und mit
Russland zu verhandeln und Russland
bis dahin nicht aber innerhalb dieses
Krise und Russland wäre an einem Punkt
verhandlungsbereit wo Vladimir Putin zu
einer internen Abwägung kommt führt
dieser Krieg überhaupt noch zu einem
Ergebnis und wird meine Lage im Lande so
schwierig dass meine macht so gefährdet
ist dass ich mich auf einen Deal
einlassen sollte und das könnte er in
einem Punkt wenn man Voraussetzungen
dafür geschaffen hat und dazu bedarf ist
der Abstimmung indem man auch jetzt mit
Russland beginnt wieder über die großen
Fragen der europäischen Sicherheit zu
reden nicht um irgendwelche Konzessionen
zu machen darum geht es nicht aber jetzt
eine Vision davon zu entwickeln wie kann
es jenseits des Krieges gelingen in
Sicherheit zusammen zu lebenden dann
könnte Wladimir in einem bestimmten
Punkt behaupten es ging mir ja immer um
die Sicherheit Russlands hier habe ich
eine Perspektive ich kann mich auf etwas
einlassen aber dazu bedarf es wie gesagt
der strategischen Abstimmung unter uns
das ist ja optimistische
punkteinsicht von Puten das Puten sowas
will weiß ich nicht optimistisch sondern
ganz nüchtern seine Abwägung gefährde
ich mit der Fortsetzung des Krieges
meine Macht zu Hause weil ich nicht mehr
in der Lage bin die zu stabilisieren
weil mir die Einnahmen wegbrechen weil
die Menschen irgendwann sich dagegen
wehren dass immer mehr Soldaten
eingezogen werden weil seine Versprechen
was er mit dem Krieg erreichen wird
nicht mehr möglich sind weil er schon
Widerspruch aus dem Militär oder sonst
wo bekommt und dann ist es eine ganz
nüchterne pragmatische
Putins Abwägung hängt ja in den
entscheidenden Maße von der
Durchhaltefähigkeit des Westens ab der
Durchhaltefähigkeit Waffen zu liefern
der Durchhaltefähigkeit die Sanktionen
aufrecht zu erhalten und was wir meine
Eindruck ist durchaus dass bei den
Waffenlieferungen man hat jetzt
zusammengekratzt was man zusammen
kratzen konnte die Produktionslinien der
Rüstungsindustrie sind offenbar nicht so
schnell hochzufahren das eine
Wiederholung der bis gelieferten Waffen
sobald tatsächlich erfolgen könnte das
heißt die Ukraine ist ein Stück weit auf
das angewiesen was sie jetzt hat was in
den nächsten Wochen Monaten bekommt für
die gegen Offensive und dann und das ist
die Frage und zu den Sanktionen wir
haben in der vergangenen Woche ja erlebt
wie mit Polen und mit Ungarn zwei
europäische Staaten sich verweigert
haben der Einfuhr von ukrainischem
Getreide weil das die Preise auf dem
heimischen Markt drückt das lässt doch
so ein bisschen Zweifeln an der ja
Durchhaltefähigkeit eben auch das
bestens genau
welche Zeitachse müssen wir uns da
einstellen Herr Mangold was denken Sie
wie lange
der Brauch ist diese militärische
Unterstützung und ist die überhaupt ja
ist das realistisch dass man die Ukraine
auch wenn man es will überhaupt so lange
unterstützen kann also würden sie das
was vorkommen bakita anspricht wie
würden Sie das sehen
es sind wirklich davon ab was man will
dass die Ukraine erreicht wie vorhin
gesagt das heißt wenn man das Kriegsziel
selenskys unterstützen möchte die Russen
auch von der Creme und aus der
Hafenstadt sebastopold zu vertreiben
wenn das das geteilte Kriegsziel ist
dann müsste die wappenunterstützung
anders aussehen das heißt die Waffen
Unterstützung müsste stärker sein aber
es ist eben auch so dass andere Staaten
eben gar nicht dieses Risiko eingehen
wollen den Krieg so weit eskalieren zu
lassen dass dazu geflossen als auch die
Krim gefährdet ist und dass deswegen
Waffen geliefert werden die der Ukraine
eine reelle Chance auf gebietgewinne
durch die früher so intensive einräumt
aber nicht die militärische Fähigkeit
gibt auch gegen die Creme vorzugehen da
ist nämlich die Furcht dass es ein
eskalationsrisiko entweder horizontal
oder vertikal geht horizontal das bei
einer solchen Eskalation des Krieges
andere Länder in den Krieg hineingezogen
werden könnten oder eben vertikal das
Russland sich doch
dazu entscheidet bei eigenen politischen
Kosten die das bringen würde gegenüber
China oder Indien und international
taktische Nuklearwaffen einzusetzen ich
halte das zwar nicht für wahrscheinlich
aber seine Möglichkeit und dieses
Restrisiko soweit ich informiert bin
bringt einige in den europäischen
Regierungen zu der Position wir
unterstützen die Ukraine für ein
begrenztes Ziel aber nicht viel
maximales kriegst ja
wie wir sie da die Position der USA aus
ist das die Frage wenn man sagt es
longert die takes also begrenztes
Kriegsziel welche zugestände müsste die
Ukraine vielleicht auch machen oder ist
es klar man steht da was auch immer die
Ukraine da möchte da steht man ich
glaube 40 Jahre wohnen die gar nicht
rein reden die wollen nicht reinmischen
und die cranes sagen wo wo wie weit die
gehen sollen die Wohnung klein und
Freiheit einfach unterstützen und nicht
nicht so politisch in den politischen
das ist Ukraine souveräne Entscheidungen
und so aber wir sind alle realistisch
und wir wissen alle das kann nicht
unendlich gehen und so und es kommt wie
sie gesagt haben vorher vielleicht eine
Regierungswechsel in den USA es kann
ganz anders ausschauen ja und Russland
käme ja bereits in eine bedrängte
Situation wenn die ukrainische
Streitkräfte gar nicht auf die krimini
übergreifen würden was in der Tat dann
erhebliche Verwaltung bedeuten würde
sondern wenn es in ukrainischen
Streitkräften gelingen sollte im
Wesentlichen den landkorrektoren
jenseits der abzuschneiden das wäre
bereits für Russland eine fatale
Situation und würde die Schwierigkeiten
Wladimir Putin auch zu Hause erheblich
erhöhen ich würde gerne nochmal auf eine
auf die Strategie schauen die Europa
Deutschland mit Russland hat oder noch
gar nicht hat Frau komm Backe was ist
ihr Eindruck gibt es eigentlich
Überlegungen für die Zeit nach dem Krieg
waren auch immer das sein muss wie unser
Verhältnis mit Russland sein kann und
wie könnte man da jetzt schon oder wird
darüber nachgedacht in welche Richtung
man das sozusagen beeinflussen kann oder
ist dieses ist das so klar dass das gar
nicht mehr geht naja die Bundesregierung
ist ja gerade dabei eine nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie zu schreiben und
eine zentrale Erkenntnis in diesem
Prozess ist offenbar das ist in Zukunft
nicht darum gehen wird Sicherheit mit
Russland auf dem europäischen Kontinent
zu schaffen sondern Sicherheit vor
Russland da ist also der Gedanke
verankert und die Idee angelegt das ist
ein konfrontatives ein konfliktreiches
mit Kinder bleiben wird perspektivisch
aber zunächst einmal geht es darum
Russland irgendwie dazu zu bewegen
diesen Krieg zu beenden und es ist ja
interessant also macron von dem eben
hier die Rede gewesen ist scheint ja
auch nochmalige weitere Bemühungen zu
unternehmen die Chinesen da ins Boot zu
holen um da mit Blick auf Sommer
Friedensgespräche zu initiieren ich bin
mir nicht ganz sicher wie abgestimmt das
innerhalb der EU ist und auch da muss
man wirklich aufpassen dass man nicht
irgendwie zu in politischen
profilierungszwecken da irgendwie
wahnsinnig viel Porzellan sehr schlägt
aber von einer von einer strategischen
Vorstellungen eines künftigen
Miteinanders mit Russland ist man glaube
ich auch deswegen noch weit entfernt
weil man nicht weiß wie dieses Russland
sich in nächster Zeit entwickeln wird
also jede Zukunft mit Russland muss
zunächst mal von einer ganz Bananen
Tatsache rausgehen die häufig übersehen
wird wir können uns Russland nicht
wegwischen es wird da bleiben und wir
müssen mit ihm umgehen und deswegen
müssen wir uns jetzt die Gedanken machen
wie können wir mit diesem Russland
umgehen Wladimir hat am 24 Februar
vergangenen Jahres eine fundamentale
Änderung der internationalen Beziehungen
vollzogen er ist aus dem Versuch eines
gestalteten friedlichen Miteinander
übergegangen eine Konfrontation in die
hat er uns gebracht und unsere Aufgabe
und deswegen müssen es unsere Gedanken
in die Zukunft auch sein wird es sein
müssen aus purerkonfrontation zumindest
geordnete Konfrontation zu machen wie es
uns in den 70er Jahren gelungen ist als
wir auch ein konfrontatives Verhältnis
hatten aber über Verabredung über
Sicherheit vertrauensbildende Maßnahmen
Rüstungskontrolle Abrüstung
sicherzustellen dass diese Konfrontation
nicht eskaliert und das muss die
Beziehung mit Russland künftig bestimmen
zu versuchen dahin zu gelangen denn wie
gesagt wir können uns nicht wegwischen
ich würde mal behaupten dass sie Putin
den konfrontationshebel nicht erst am 24
Februar vergangenen Jahres umgelegt hat
sondern schon 25 20 Jahre zuvor
allmählich und wir wollten es bloß nicht
wahrhaben und eine wäre vielleicht da
ist ein genauer hinzuschauen würde ich
nicht zustimmen denn wir sehen wenn wir
zurückblicken dass Russland immer eine
prinzipielle Bereitschaft behalten hat
sich auch auf verhandelte Lösungen
einzulassen selbst 2014 als jeder
glaubte er marschiert in seinem Krieg
aus dem Donbass durch nach Kiew das war
die Analyse aller westlichen
Geheimdienste zumindest in den USA und
Großbritannien hat er sich am Ende auf
diese Minsker Verabredungen eingelassen
die so seine eigene Analyse im Rückblick
für ihn gar nicht vorteilhaft waren also
es hat so Hobby Rossmann immer
umgegangen ist schon diese Bereitschaft
denn gleich da stimme ich ihn zu
abnehmend gegeben aber das ist mit der
Zeitenwende deswegen ist der Begriff
richtig vom 24 Februar definitiv beendet
Herr mein Gott was würden Sie sagen was
wäre die richtige ja Strategie gegenüber
Russland wenn man sagt wir brauchen
Sicherheit vor Russland und nicht mehr
mit Russland aber gleichzeitig mit
diesem was er von Fritz gesagt hat wir
können uns das Land nicht wegdenken
und es hängt natürlich wesentlich vom
Ausgang dieses Knie gesagt für das
völlig unrealistische Szenario das
Russland sicher auf einen
verhandlungsfrieden einlässt der der
Ukraine wesentliche Forderungen
zugesteht wird das Verhältnis des
Westens zu Russland natürlich anders
aussehen nur das System ein sehr
unrealistisches Szenario das Szenario
ist eben realistisch dass die
konfrontative Haltung der russischen
hauspolitik bestehen bleibt deswegen bin
ich eigentlich der Ansicht die
politische Isolation muss bleiben die
Aufrüstung gegen Russland muss vorwärts
gehen die Sanktionen müssen bleiben aber
ich stimme dem Herrn Botschafter von
Fritz zu dass man natürlich diese
Konfrontation die bleiben wird solange
Latin ihr putinander macht ist dass man
diese Konfrontation in geordneten Bahnen
hält und Gesprächskanäle offen lässt
aber ein aufeinander zugehen sie ist
nicht so lange bleibt sie mir putinander
macht ist und das kann er noch lange der
Fall sein oder solche Putin bei einem
ungünstigen Kriegsverlauf gestürzt
werden ist es ja auch wahrscheinlich
dass jemand aus dem Geheimdienst
milieusen Nachfolger wird die gleichen
anti-westlichen Einstellungen haben die
Vladimir Putin mit so einem Nachfolger
natürlich wäre auch kein sich wieder
annähern möglich man muss ja
realistischerweise sagen es gibt in
Russland keinen westfreundlichen
Politiker der auch nur den Hauch einer
Chance hätte die Macht zu ergreifen also
was das betrifft wird es noch lange so
bleiben Annalena baerbock hat auf dem
g7-treffen gesagt niemand auf der Welt
wünscht sich eine neue
Blockkonfrontation
steuern wir genau darauf zu aber ich
glaube dieser Satz speist sich aus dem
Eindruck und der Sorge dass die
russische Lesart dieses Konflikts die
russische Deutung global verfängt das
z.B auf dem afrikanischen Kontinent ist
viele Vertreter gibt die dem Westen die
Schuld an hohen Energiepreisen
Export Problematiken zuschreiben und ähm
das dasselbe sie mit mir gerade auch
ganz intensiv mit Brasilien ja Brasilien
die Schule das silver der neue Präsident
dessen dessen war ja von vielen hier in
Europa beklatscht worden ist er weiß
sich doch als ja ziemlich fordernder
Partner wenn er der Ukraine eine
Mitschuld am Krieg gibt wenn er dem
Westen namentlich den USA vorwirft mit
Waffenlieferungen den Konflikt noch
weiter anzuheizen
da merkt man Russland ist eben mit
nichten so isoliert wie wie das hier im
Westen manchmal
behaupten oder oder glauben mögen also
das russische nativ verfängt im
sogenannten globalen Süden und es ist
dieser Satz von Werbung den sie zitiert
haben war im Prinzip ja so eine
ausgestreckte Hand an jene Staaten die
da irgendwo sich jetzt dazwischen fühlen
und sich aber gar nicht entscheiden
wollen für eine Seite für das autoritäre
russische chinesische System oder
die Frage wie weit man ja eben diese
Hand noch weiter ausstrecken könnte
inwieweit man da noch Einfluss drauf
nehmen
verfängt nicht die Mehrheit der
afrikanischen Staaten hat in den
Vereinten Nationen sich der Resolution
141 Staaten angeschlossen die Russland
verurteilt haben zwei meiner Abstand
eines Jahres 35 Staaten haben sich
enthalten china hat sich nicht auf
Russland Seite geschlagen und auf
Russland Seite waren solche Großmächte
wie Weißrussland Nordkorea und Eritrea
ungefähr fünf Staaten das heißt im Kern
stimmen alle Staaten unserer lese ab
schon zu aber priorisieren zufällig 100
über 180 staatenabteil genommen von 66
Mitglieder das ist kein sehr großer
Abwesenheit und wenn wir auf die Haltung
anderer Staaten schauen müssen wir sehen
dass sie ihre außenpolitischen
Prioritäten anders setzen ganz
spannendes Beispiel ist Indien eine
Milliarde Menschen die man arithmetisch
dann irgendwie immer auf die Seite
Russland schlägt was ich für falsch
halte aus dem Politik ist keine
Mathematik wo steht denn Indien dänische
außenministerpräsident haben völlig klar
gemacht dass sie gegen Gewalt in den
internationalen Beziehungen sind gegen
Annexion gegen jede Form der Verletzung
der un-kater aber was ist Indiens
Interesse sein großer rival ist China
wer ist Chinas Freund Russland wo kaufe
ich meine Waffen in Russland wer wird
gerade in meinem reversierten Nachbarn
Pakistan stark China all das muss Indien
balancieren und wir müssen stärker im
Versuch auch auf diese Staaten zuzugehen
ich finde das macht diese wie die vorige
Bundesregierung nicht schlecht die
spezifische Interessenlage dieser
Partner berücksichtigen versuchen da
anzusetzen auf der Grundlage einer
großen Übereinstimmung bei dem
Prinzipien der internationalen Politik
mit Ihnen gemeinsam Politik machen und
das kann gelingen
er mein Gott was würden sie dachte sie
wollen was anderes was würden Sie sagen
wenn wir sagen langjähriger Krieg lange
Krieg ähm denken sie da über fünf oder
zehn Jahre nach also was sind die
Dimensionen eigentlich in denen wir
denken müssen
so ist natürlich völlige Spekulation
jetzt zu sagen da dauert zwei drei oder
vier Jahre das kann niemand
ehrlicherweise sagen aber man kann sagen
Kriege können auf drei Arten Enden der
erst die erste Art ist eine dritte
Partei interveniert und erzwingt einen
Friedensschluss den zweite Art ist eine
der beiden Kriegsparteien setzt sich
militärisch durch und diktiert dann den
Frieden oder die dritte Variante beide
Kriegsparteien sind irgendwann
militärisch so erschöpft dass es sich
einfach keine Gewinne mehr auf dem
Schlachtfeld ausrechnen und dann doch
bereits in gemeinsam über eine Lösung zu
verhandeln ich kann nur sagen von allen
diesen drei Szenarien sind wir in der
Ukraine derzeit sehr weit entfernt und
was bedeutet es wenn diese
Frühjahrsoffensive also wenn die Ukraine
ist schafft auf irgendeiner war zum
teilweise die russischen Truppen
zurückzubringen
nun wenn das gelingt dann glaube ich
dass die Chancen der Ukraine sehr viel
größer sind dass die westliche
Unterstützung anhält wie gesagt mit
diesem Vorbehalt wie weit man die
Ukraine gehen lassen möchte wenn die
Offensive nicht gelingt oder nur sehr
geringe territoriale Rückeroberungen
bringt dann glaube ich wird der Druck
auf die Ukraine steigen sich doch auf
einen Gespräch zumindest mit Russland
einzulassen auch ohne diese
Vorbedingungen weit aufrecht zu halten
dass die Ukraine mit Russland erst
spricht wenn Russland alles eine Truppen
aus der Ukraine zurückgezogen hat
inklusive der Klima ich kann mir
gegenwärtig noch keine Situation
vorstellen in der eine westliche
Regierung von der Ukraine verlangen
würde Konzession an Russland zu machen
nicht nur weil es gegenüber der Ukraine
unerträglich wäre sondern auch weil es
ein fatales Signal in die internationale
Politik sind senden würde Anwendungen
von Gewalt lohnt sich Putin hat sich
irgendwo durchgesetzt und er würde sich
von ihm oder er würde sich ermutigt
fühlen weiterzumachen dann holt er sich
drei Jahre aus dann ist Georgien dran
oder wäre auch immer vielen Dank Herr
Kirschbaum
für die Diskussion ihnen vielen Dank
fürs zuschauen wir sind morgen wieder
für Sie da dann schauen wir auf die
Proteste der klimaaktivisten die heute
die Hauptstadt ein bisschen lahmlegen
wollten es glaube es ist nicht ganz so
gelungen aber wir schauen mal was denn
denn dieser Proteste im Klimaschutz
wirklich bringt und jetzt geht's weiter
mit Phoenix der Tag mit Maja Weber bis
dann tschüss
[Musik]